what am I most likely to be doing at a
party
looking for Timmy Chalmer
wait a minute what was
you were doing the GQ couple quiz
Tucker what is my full name first middle
and last Emma Francis chamberton
you know what sure
what city did I grow up in
already alrighty you guys all ready
no it's not okay I know it's been there
I know it's where the airport is SFO yes
it's yep San yes
yes
nice nice nice there's a lot of Sands in
um northern California what are my
parents names
stove
okay you can't be abbreviating
you need to you need to say with
your chest
and
this is the worst thing I only know CP
as like CP it's Mike we call yes it's
Mike okay Michael and Sophia next what
are my cats names
Declan and Frankie where was our first
date it was at your house yeah and it
was
playing fortnite because I had to
pretend to enjoy that game for you and
enjoy video games in general for you
when we first started talking
I was like
really into fortnite and it was not a
joke I just loved it I just loved the
game me too me too that's actually one
of my favorites of them how many tattoos
do I have
I know it's hard I can barely even
remember and it's my own arm you
know I kind of practiced this the other
day though okay she separates them
she has one arm for her dad and one arm
for her mama on your dad's you have a
number here is you have your dad's car
cool you have the paint brushes yep you
have
this like doodle you have a word
on your arm that he calls you uh-huh yep
Lighthouse yep okay
let's go to your mom's button yeah
the word that she calls you yeah yeah
big Z
Iggy baby sorry
um piggy bank oh the pun the pine tree
you know what I don't even remember you
got and the bonus points and the
squirrels those bonus points you did
amazing that was really impressive and
you even knew the meaning so I think
that it's safe to say you're an awesome
boyfriend thank you so much what food do
we eat together the most right now
yeah like fair enough where do I hang
out in my house the most when I'm alone
uh you're bad no
you're bad not right now
my desk
okay true what's my favorite item in my
house well right now you're working on a
big photo wall
which includes your dad's paintings
which I would include love okay great
love that what are my favorite shoes to
actually wear like what do you think I
wear the most frequently hugs and birds
I don't know about the Berks but I think
the Uggs are about are like true uh
okay that's that's good what word do I
overuse personally not us me what word
do I overuse
I don't know I don't know I do think I
say like a lot
I know
it's not even a word what was my first
video on my YouTube channel of all time
it is still up unfortunately okay well I
know that when you started you were
still in school okay and you would
literally just like film your like day
yeah at school and after school
vlogging because you've experimented a
lot with like smoke tricks I remember
when you were like yeah like babe tricks
you sure do like slow-mo edits of her
like that's actually how she became huge
so
describe a perfect day for me okay wake
up I don't want to give up your workout
place but you go to a certain place I
love my morning exercise for sure
workout class that you can possibly take
you have a love affair with your
personal trainer so I don't know why I
don't even have one and yes you do so
wake up early and they have her coffee
that coffee does what it does I poop
work out ideally in the morning
get the body right for summer
um dear podcasts I guess that's work
though like
not that it feels like work
but that's
incredible you guys no she's a loose
cannon he actually is a loose kid I am
scared of the comments to come no I know
we have a lot to worry about okay wait
what's my favorite drink to order at a
restaurant say alcoholic version and
non-alcoholic there I know not an
alcoholic that is not true it's changed
it's been a vodka soda with I'm not
kidding 8 000 limes and she
dumps it and it's like if you take a sip
it is like well can we be honest I
squeeze and then dump if you just like
dumped limes in there you wouldn't get
any like battery acid she loves battery
acid she doesn't beat it better
yesterday no but that's not my drink
anymore now it's just a tequila soda
with still battery acid lime this is so
this is like I'm actually scared for
this name three Chamberlain coffee
products and describe the character on
the label night owl
[Music]
Fox there is a fox yep do you know what
flavor early bird great done none of
them has an animal on it like I have
your tumbler I use it every day he does
it's very very cool so she's a tumbler
and she's actually coming out with a
much cooler one that is hitting stores
it's awesome and I'm gonna be using that
too you should be too
I'm trying to sell your
okay how did you first hear of me I
didn't know you from YouTube but I saw
you on Tick Tock and there was one
specific Tech talk for you
you were in your bathroom
and you were
twerking okay I was not twerking stop
stop it's cute it ends up cute so just
let it go you guys she was attempting to
twerk in her bathroom and she it was to
a day glow song which those two things
don't exist together ever but
and you surprised yourself because I
think your ass like moved a little bit
yeah
wow what am I most likely to be doing at
a party
looking for Timmy Charlemagne
wait a minute what was the question
that was the best you've ever said
and by the way and that's true in her
defense it's usually like a team effort
like we will scope we're looking for him
so that because like we're just trying
to hang with him
sorry what is one thing
that I will never wear a dress
I'll give you another try because I do
wear dresses well okay on your own like
by choice that's true
low waisted jeans that's also true you
know what point Tucker how many points
do I have well let me show you
I I feel really confident in my ability
to just recall information about Tucker
I feel like I have a really nice Tucker
storage unit in my mind what is my phone
name
first middle and last name
the prince like if
like if my prince where am I from you're
from Maine what town Cape Elizabeth
Maine nice I've been to Cape Elizabeth
multiple times many times so wouldn't it
be a little weird if I didn't know
it would be I know you know that that
was easy we got started I mean so far
we're starting easy okay how many
tattoos do I have
or you don't know do you know you might
have like
he's trying to be like MGK
does that make me
like right here
okay all right chill okay what artist
inspired me the most growing up the
thing that's confusing me is that you
have a Bob Marley poster in your bedroom
your childhood bedroom so like I want to
say Bob Marley but I know it's not Bob
Marley because that's you're gonna get
me destroyed on the internet sorry sorry
Elvis Elvis okay are any of my songs
about you I mean you said yet so so yeah
so yeah
that's correct how about this name three
songs that you
know or about you
this is up okay name three okay
stop getting out never let you go
okay
no it wouldn't be better to sing it oh
my God said to me I told you to come
have sex with me
okay blind cool okay one more RX cool
okay easy rock on what are my parents
names Susan and Rusty also known as
Graham I'm gonna add on to this
name my siblings
and the pets Morgan and Alex are the
siblings
Banner
and Rhonda are the past I had no say in
any of the names so don't come from it
how did I get started in music
you were in college yes and you weren't
feeling so good
you weren't having a good time that felt
so good you weren't feeling so good and
so you had like friends who were doing
music or something or you like new
people who were doing music yes and they
like left their stuff yes in your dorm
yes and then you were like ah and you
started playing around with it and
you're like this feels pretty good and
it and it fired you up a little bit and
you're like let's keep going good job
stay with me
what instruments do I play guitar and
who taught me my dad
[Music]
okay well my dad knows how to play my
dad knows how to play every instrument
like beautiful fingers and he just
I'm so sorry Dad if you're watching this
I know you're watching this that was so
inappropriate CP I love you what's my
biggest fear
oh shoot we have talked about this
recently okay wait is it something
that's like oh
wait this is kind of dark Tucker okay
then that's probably not it swimming at
night that's so not true we just talked
about
Sharkies if I could live in one place in
the world where would it be like maybe
Maine but I
you and they're right there
you what is the first concert I ever
went to
Jonas Brothers
true
I was true that was with my mom and that
was a Valentine's Day gift from my mom
my mom got me the tickets because Nick
has diabetes and I do too and so I think
it was like a it's gonna be okay son
and look look what you can do name three
of my first jobs you worked at a crepe
shop you worked at an ice cream shop you
worked for a landscaping company you
were a babysitter slash Nanny sure they
still can't find those kids okay I know
I made a very dark joke but nannying was
like my favorite thing for some reason
it was like up as I am I actually
like enjoy kids but ice cream was
probably the best job it's probably why
I got diabetes
Okay so okay what who made the first
move you
how did you first hear of me
I first heard of you from a mutual
friend that we have yes because they
were telling me role model is the man
for you showed me a pic of you and I was
like here
I'm a little worried about this energy
because
I just feel as though you know it's
gonna he's not he just doesn't give me
loyal energy
and can I be honest it was the tattoos I
was like too many every tattoo is like a
little less loyal and I gave Tucker a
chance
and he proved me wrong
give him a chance give him a chance what
is my favorite
band
I mean yeah oh in 1975. yeah where did I
go to college and what did I major in
you went to name the school do you know
that
don't say anything because I actually I
know I do it's in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania yeah and it had something
with Park in it don't tell me actually
you're gonna Point Park Point Park in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania so good where
did the name role model
I'm from it was just an ironic thing
because it was a joke it was just kind
of a joke because you're like I'm not a
role model so I'm calling myself role
model what do I prefer
text
or voice memo or DM it would be
different with me versus like other
people no do you know what I'm saying
between us what do we do
FaceTime always that's my favorite as
well am I ticklish
actually no and I've really tested I've
tested all the limits there is a farm
across the street from my childhood home
strawberries
hey Emma you got this many points
he has been known to cheat at games such
as Uno Monopoly things of that sort
she's a liar and we know that and we
went over that thank you so much guys
thank you guys for watching GQ
VIs
[Music]